bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france pour parler de
la situation dans votre quartier à la
courneuve il ya eu une mobilisation iard
contre le trafic de drogue
expliquez-nous là la situation que vous
vivez actuellement
bonjour veaux et merci de nous recevoir
il ya une manifestation à l'appel du mai
45 en collaboration avec la mairie les
habitants et les commerçants du quartier
l'objectif c'était de manifester contre
tous types d'actes illicites qui s'y
déroulent depuis un certain moment dans
la place notamment la vente de
cigarettes illicites
trafic de drogue les agressions
multiples que certains peuvent-ils bien
et du coup hier on a fermé les boutiques
entre 18h et 19h pour exprimer notre
ras-le-bol face à cette situation parce
que ça dure depuis combien de temps et
pourquoi ça ça embête et ça empoisonne
la vie des commerçants dont vous êtes le
représentant ce matin
ça fait quelques années déjà qu'on va
dire deux trois ans et du coup ça occupe
l'espace public la clientèle quand elle
est sur place elle l est pas sereine il
ya toujours un risque de se faire
agresser d'un seul et tout ça quoi il ya
beaucoup d'agressions vous constatez oui
nous sur ces dernières années on voit
qu'il ya pas mal d'agression surtout ce
sont les femmes qui sont ciblés en fait
peut-être que c'est plus facile à leur
soutirer quelque chose à nos migaud ps
et de se battre plus qu'une pas et quand
vous avez trois quatre personnes autour
de vous au mieux sur quoi alors vous
vous êtes mobilisés que d'isoler les
pouvoirs publics locaux pour pour
essayer d'endiguer ce phénomène
manifestations et hier elle a été faite
alors que la boire à city il était
présent à la manifestation et il réclame
aussi plus de présence notamment de
police sur le terrain par exemple parce
que là il n'y en a pas suffisamment vous
avez entendu le chef de l'état hier qui
s'est félicité de son bilan à la
courneuve vous avez vu du changement il
ya eu des renforts policiers on a vu un
une légère amélioration mais c'est pas
suffisant il faudra faire beaucoup plus
pour que on est un climat stable
quel est le type de population justement
que vous dénoncez ces trafiquants de
drogue est ce que ce sont plutôt des
jeunes plutôt des des personnes issues
de milieux défavorisés
oui c'est clair c'était personnes de
milieux défavorisés c'est des très
jeunes
donc au là ils sont un peu en recherche
d'une stabilité du coup ça les pousse à
faire des choses un trek le trafic de
drogue dont vous parlez une prend quelle
forme
on ne serait pas vous dire exactement
quelle forme prend parce qu'on reste un
peu à l'écart de tout ça ne vous savez
on est commercial juste qu'on en est là
bas ce sont plage tous les jours mais
par mesure de sécurité on s'accroche pas
trop de ça
vous êtes commerçant quelles sont les
répercussions sur vos commerces
j'imagine que économiquement aussi ça ne
va pas tellement attirer les clients
surtout aujourd'hui dans un contexte de
crise comme une
perte de chiffre d'affaires mais
certains clients une crainte de venir
dans chaque quartier là du coup
forcément on est impacté le chiffre
d'affaires alors qu'est ce que vous
réclamez concrètement puisque le
j'imagine que vous en appelez à l'état
aujourd'hui bien sûr d'aujourd'hui nous
demande c'est que il ya un peu plus de
présence qu'on puisse résoudre ce
problème en fait parce que pour nous
c'est de jour en jour c'est pire donc on
espère avec la collaboration de l'état
de la mairie qui arrive à une solution
pour ce problème merci beaucoup merci
jouanny damnation merci de nous avoir
livré votre témoignage ce matin dans la
matinale rt france